good morning welcome to this meeting of
weber planning committee i will now ask
the government's officer
to read out domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations for you
thank you chair
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you are
sitting down or for your exempt from
doing so and that you use the sand and
hand sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking if you are attending
the meeting to speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
finally we will be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern gov app so
please could members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately via a fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point at
ipswich town football ground follow the
signs directing you to the fire exit at
each end of the floor do not enter the
atrium ground floor area and walkways if
you are in the atrium at the time of the
alarm follow the signs to the nearest
fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts do not
re-enter the building until told it is
safe to do so
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be required recorded except
where there are confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to consent into being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to be recorded
by the council and to the possible use
of those sound recordings for webcasting
and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and press are not lawfully excluded
thank you chair thank you
now make some introductions chief
planning officer phillies bow
the legal adviser ian de pray
strategic projects and delivery manager
stephen stroud
case officers today are joe
joe hobbs and vincent pierce
thank you
um
board members for this particular one
are myself and councillor halt and we'll
come to those in the moment
come over to the agenda please yes
do you have any apologies of absence
yeah we have apologies from councillor
simon barrett
uh councillor michael holt is
substituting thank you
how many declarations of
pecuniary or non-pecunian dress by
members
nope
thank you
ryan
can we please confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 11th of august you
all should have received
a copy
are there any corrections that need to
be made
that anybody has noticed
if not
can i have a proposal to accept them
counselor beer
secondary councillors
now conduct an electronic vote if we can
all remember how to get into it
thank you chair members if you select
the plus sign on the top right hand
corner of your agenda of your agenda in
mod gov
select attendance and voting this vote
is now in progress
thank you members chair that's ten votes
four and one abstention thank you very
much
we also have
the minutes of the meeting held on the
25th of august
are there any points of accuracy or
correction does anyone wish to erase
no in that case could i have a proposal
to accept the mayor's council hopes and
counts
and the second
council mclaren thank you
hello conduct another vote
members that is in progress
thank you members chair that's ten sorry
eleven votes for seven that's really
nervous
thank you
moving on
oh sorry
mr chairman can i just uh the recent
police liaison
meeting for the eastern part of baber
this site was mentioned
the site that was included in the
minutes that we just passed was
mentioned and i see from the minutes it
does say
that security gates and security
provisions have been put in place it
doesn't say what has actually been put
in place because there were concerns
that areas like that were going to be
used by people congregating to river
illegal noisy motor cars etc
which application was that please cancel
sorry
what top of bobbitt's lane
station
[Music]
can i ask you to liaise with
steven stroud after the meeting exactly
which one you're concerned we'll do
thanks john we'll move on
if you
any other comments
if not we'll move on to receive
notification and petitions
let me save that thank you site
inspections are there any requests
no no right
right moving on to schedule of planning
applications
dc 2100 754 gcb factory and premises
laura glemsfield
this stage i must ask council hulk will
you be speaking to a war member or
staying on the committee
i'll be staying on the conversation
thank you
and chair as a board member can i
confirm if you will be staying on the
committee i will stand
invite the case officer joe hobbs to
introduce the application to the
committee joe all yours
lovely thank you chair
so the application for members today um
is at the gcb factory premises low road
in glensford just as that
highlighted here on the um on the slide
the application is a full application
and
in summary it's for extensions and
alterations to the factory premises to
accommodate a chocolate production
facility and the proposal is in full on
page one of the committee report that
details all of the extensions
alterations but i will go through those
in my slide
in my slides
just to point out the table papers that
members will have hopefully received and
just to update uh the lead floating
authority have withdrawn their objection
and we have had further information on
air quality from the applicants although
that's yet to be um consulted on and
reported on as members will most likely
note from the conclusion to this
committee report is slightly different
to usual and that we haven't
put a recommendation forwards to members
we've brought the application to
committee for the sake of moving the
application along due to the economic
implications of the
site coming back into use
but there are still
well there is still one key matter of
air quality and impact on a natural
environment that is yet to be resolved
so today officers are asking for
delegated authority from the committee
to go away and resolve those issues but
ultimately officers are working towards
approval of the scheme
so um one final update
which was received yesterday that's not
the table of papers there's just suffolk
um highways maintaining no objection
just noting that there's no footpath
possible to the site but they're happy
with the travel plan that's just one
further update two notes um but it
doesn't change the substantive comments
in the committee report from the highway
authority
okay so if we
run through the site and the proposals
just to give an outline to members so
here we have the application site um
this is shown at the village of
glensford here and the a1092 just
running along the application site here
let's get to the next slide uh here's
the site location plan of the site
showing the red line where all the
proposed works are and the blue line
other land within the applicant's
ownership
just to go through the constraints now
um here you'll see the site is on the
suffolk essex county border
baber and then brainstorm district
council
the flood zones are shown in blue in
hatch
the actual application site is outside
of uh flood zone um two and three
although some of the surface water
features um are within the harris flood
zones um
but the majority of the built form
development is all within flood zone one
there's also tpos on the site just that
little collection of trees just there
just to go through the
list of buildings there are a number of
list of buildings
that have been examined through these
proposals as you'll see from the
proposals shortly the proposed the
extensions are quite tall and so there
are a number of heritage assets which
have been assessed
for the impact on the setting of those
territories assets
close to the site we have the church of
st mary grade one
uh we have a glamorous conservation area
australian purple hatch down there
we have some barns at lodge farm which
are a non-designated heritage asset
uh three turns former public house also
non-designated heritage asset and potash
house um grade two listed building
and on the main road we've got one to
three low road um which are also greater
listed buildings
just looking at the wider scheme as the
buildings are quite large we have to
look towards longmelford as well so we
have kentwell hall grade two star listed
building registered park and gardens
and we also have
church of holy trinity grade one in long
melford and melford hall grade one
listed building so they all have a
degree of impact as set out in the
committee report um
the the set it to the set their settings
and we also have long male for
conservation area which is impacted
other constraints include the star
valley project area the site isn't
within the area of outstanding natural
beauty and that's located here the dark
green but it is within the project area
so it doesn't have the
status of an area of outstanding natural
beauty
so we don't interpret that in terms of
the policies but it's to note that it is
an area of landscape sensitivity and
also adjacent to the site it's a special
landscape area which i'll show you on a
slide in a moment
so the special landscape area is this
area shown here in purple the site isn't
within it but it is nearby the site
so this slide shows the ecological
constraints the um
the horizontal bars horizontal green
bars on these sites here and here showed
two treble sis near the site that we're
currently assessing to see the impact of
the proposals on those treble sis the
glimmer pits wraps around the um
application site but also kentwood woods
further to the north
and so now i'll just run through the
proposals so members can understand why
we've kind of looked at so many
constraints on such a wide area
because the extensions like i say do
have a certain height and the proposed
nature do lead to some emissions from
the site uh the nature of the proposal
so that's why we've got these issues
that we're running through
so here we have an existing site plan
i've just highlighted the buildings to
try to draw them out a little bit the
existing building a is 12 meters and its
highest point although it's a variety of
heights across the
site and building b is 11 meters at its
highest point and now the two key uh
buildings on site at the moment accessed
by here
and
car park
for present car park here
here's the proposed site plans for just
to draw out there's three main
components we have the proposed
chocolate building um cocoa building
apologies we'll call it the middle one
is coco building
the i've highlighted it all in yellow
but that's just the overall footprint
it's 40 meters at its highest point but
not across the whole of this
footprint i'll show you elevation
shortly to show which component is 40
meters high
and then building
b the chocolate building
that is 19 meters high at its highest
again not across the whole point of the
site but one component is that tall
and then the third building is a new
building proposed in the car park area
which is a biomass boiler at 25.7 metres
at its highest point so just to give
remember some information on what the
proposals are for this site um the
proposal is our chocolate production
facility um but it is proposed to
actually process the um cocoa beans on
the site so the middle building here
will be processing the actual raw
material of the cocoa building a cocoa
product
chocolate products will then be made
into chocolate and bars other chocolate
products in building b
and the biomass boiler is being used to
burn the coco shells
so and then obviously the renewable
energy from that site is then fed back
into the
other processes on the site
so one of the outstanding
issues we have on the application is air
quality and it relates to the biomass
boiler and the emissions from that
biomass boiler just understanding um the
nitrogen dioxide
volatile organic compounds and
particulates matters that come out of
that and making sure we have adequate
mitigation in place to make sure there's
no adverse impact on the treble size
such as a
nitrogen deposition in that area
just to uh also there's some other
ancillary structures around the site but
they're relatively small such as weight
bridges and such like
and just to give an idea the total
proposed floor space is 31 000 um 752
square meters with a net floor space
gain on the site of
3949 so
without going to the plans and a huge
amount of detail different flaws are
being
reconfigured and established in building
b um and building a bit obviously being
extended and altered but there's a net
gain of 3949
square meters
overall
also just to note this revised entrance
just to enable vehicles to come in and
move around the site
so just to try and give an idea of the
um elevations on the building now i'm
just going to go through the existing uh
buildings and
the proposed elevations and then some
photo visuals that have been generated
off the proposed buildings
so existing building a is moving to um
this is the building b so this is the
building which is 40 meters at its
highest point as you see it's not across
the whole of the building it's just too
um
part of the site there
and just to go to existing elevations on
the building
and that's just showing the um buildings
all sides of the buildings to give an
idea of the extent of the uh the higher
part of the building
also just to show cross section of the
building to show what's going on inside
the building so the reason for the
heights for building a as due to this
planting machinery in here so there will
be an open um space in this section of
the building where the plant machinery
goes up all the way to the top of the
roof here
we've been discussing with the
applicants the need for the height to
see whether it could be reduced at all
um without affecting um operations and
we've discussed lots of options about
sinking the plant into the floor to see
if we can try and kind of bring the
height of the building down by making um
the kind of equipment underground in
part um but we haven't been able to find
a kind of a cost-effective solution um
but there is um
there's a we've also investigated why
the building needs to be that high and
from a production point of view it does
lead to a much
higher quality um cocoa product from the
end of the production
and i'm sure the applicant can explain
the process um if there are any
questions from members but we have tried
to look at reducing that that relatively
uh that component of the scheme um but
we can't find a solution that allows
basically the operation to effectively
and um
operate
so just to go through i'm not going to
go through all the floor plans um
because they are a little bit of a
myriad i do have them if members are
interested but just to show as i said we
have plant machinery in this section of
the building we have storage in this
section of the building and other
ancillary office structures
but just to give an idea we have some
photo visuals so the building uh we'll
talk about building a here the coco
building is this one here
and this is the biomass boiler i'll show
that again in a slide in the moment and
the um the car park and here members
will see uh the proposed material we've
had a slide at the end of showing some
photo visuals of that in the wider area
but it is a reflective material
we've gone through all the different
options with the aomb officers as well
in discussion with them to see what
would be the best material
and it's considered that a reflective
material probably works best in our
inclement weather in the uk and putting
anything perhaps so like a grey building
would be um perhaps more noticeable in
this river valley area and it's also
been suggested that natural kind of more
earthy materials are also used but given
the height we felt that this reflective
material will be the best design
solution to really kind of
help it uh kind of work best with the
surrounding landscape that it sets
within
so just to run through building b and
building c these are the existing
elevations of building b
the footprint for building b uh will
stay the same with its internal
alterations and one small extent of
extensions which i've just run back to
that slide just this section here that's
the increased height but the largest it
sits within its existing footprint this
building
and that's just effective vision of it
there so that's the existing building
you might recognize the kind of um
kind of the curve that's already present
it's just that small
extension on that section there and to
the right there that's part of building
a the lower side of building a
and the biomass spoiler just to run
through those um proposals we've got the
elevations here
uh inside the cross section to show what
the floor plan is showing the plant that
will be housed within
and then that visual you'll remember
from earlier that's the building see
there
so
before you can you go back to that slide
25 yes
i thought the coco building was 40
meters and the biomass is about 29. yes
that's correct sorry yeah that's the 40
meter building um 40 meter component
there and this is 27 it's the aspect
that you're looking at it from this um
plan because also you're closer to the
biomass building and that
higher section is further away so the
perspective um kind of it perhaps makes
the 27th meter building look a little
bit taller but it's uh it's closer to
you on site
it's just the fact that the 40 meter
building is further away which is why it
almost looks the same level
okay council above it
okay
yeah thank you
just to run through the landscape
viewpoints now there are a few of these
but there have been quite a few
discussions obviously with our landscape
architect and the aonb officer to the
landscape impact of this scheme as it is
quite tall within the river valley and
it does break the horizon from several
viewpoints i'm just going to go through
those viewpoints so members are aware of
the um the landscape impact of the
proposal um so on each slide i have the
position of the um where the photos
taken from and a few of the slides also
have wire lines of the proposed building
so
from public footpaths in glensford you
can see it sits just um under the
horizon just there
looking down
is that existent or is that what we've
proposed oh yeah sorry that's proposed
thank you
and yes and existing is obviously um
what you can see underneath the blue
line um and then the post is the uh yeah
the blue wire line
so here's the public footpath going down
towards lodge farm
looking down towards the site see it
will break the horizon um from this
viewpoint
this doesn't have a wire line on at this
site but from this public footpath um
the um
building would also break the skyline so
it would be above the
existing uh that line of kind of trees
and horizon there
where
can you tell us
is that from glensberg's side or is that
from the south side it's glamsford from
public right of way so if you're walking
across the public right-of-way that just
gets across the kind of the south or
some of the houses um in glensfield
there
and again this is just slightly uh
further down from lodge farms so further
down from where we were before again it
will break the skyline it won't be at
the dotted red line but it will break
the skyline um of the
horizon there
this is the listed building potter's
house you can just see behind here and
although appreciate not too clearly from
the distance in these screens but you
can just see there the blue wire line so
you will get glimpse views um in the
distance of the setting of that listed
building and the harms are set out as
set out in the committee report to at
least the building
so here we are on style close this is
directly next to the site the biomass
boiler is proposed just in this area
here there's residential dwellings um
just on the right here
um and it shows the kind of the extent
of the the built form so there'll be a
visual impact when you're
looking here
and here is the turning to glensford
from the 1092 you can just see the blue
wire line there of how the building will
sit when you're
driving along the road there from what
you'll see
and this is further back from one to
three lower roads these are listed
buildings on one three lower road and
you can just see
between the trees there a glimpse of the
building the proposed building
the application as we said is on the uh
essex um suffolk border and so uh um
landscape assessment has been made from
the braintree side as well so we've got
two viewpoints here you already see the
1092 running along the slide there so
we've got the essex suffolk board around
there and we've got views from public
rights of way
within
braintree and the proposals will break
the horizon here as well so it will be
visually noticeable from those those
viewpoints as well
got two more viewpoints now we've got
public right of way in glenswood's main
village there public right of way
further over here
looking towards the site again it will
um break the horizon
and looking further away and you'll see
a wire line on this uh slide here which
actually zoomed in on the photo a little
bit more but you can see how it just
breaks the horizon here
as well
this is the uh a slider that the
applicants produce to show alternative
materials this is the proposed material
and how it's considered it will work
within the landscape you can see
reflection of kind of the you know the
kind of colours of the sky and the
landscape at lower level we've looked at
um other um natural kind of colours as
well but you'll see it does lead to more
of a visual impact if you have
a kind of a non-reflective material
quite frankly and so that's why the um
proposals of the uh
vertical trapezoidal uh mirror
material is proposed
so just to go through a couple of photos
of the sites to provide members this is
what will be the chocolate building
building b
and this is existing um building a which
will largely stay at this level here but
also we'll have the larger extension and
to the rear of this building
and just uh views of looking down the
road but just to uh point out the
neighbors to the um application site we
obviously have stone cottages which are
um down uh just where the lace be lace
is pointing there
and just looking down towards um style
close
sites on the left and we have style
close here
and these neighbors will obviously have
an impact in the meantime as set out in
the committee report and it wouldn't
it's not considered solution
unacceptable impact community but it
would be an impact to the outlook of
those residents um from the proposed
developments
uh and also i thought it's important to
have a look into style close so this is
in style close um whereas residents
dwellings are we're looking towards
where the biomass boiler will be
along the boundary proposed to keep this
vegetation
um but there'll be a biomass boiler just
behind this area here that will be the
27 meter building
along here
and that's just one more picture of
stone and cottages along there
so um just to bring into summary where
we are in the application the
application is in in basic form an
extension to an existing employment site
um but obviously there are notable
significant landscape harms
and also harm to heritage assets which
almost must be taken with the utmost
importance
there's impact on residential immunity
but as details in the report with
planned conditions we feel they could be
suicidally addressed such as
conditions relating to noise both
construction and operational phase and
also lighting to ensure that's kept
minimum and no additional lighting is
proposed to the existing
lighting on the site
we still need to look further into the
air quality impact with natural england
to find appropriate to ensure we have
fully understood the impacts of the
biomass boiler
and the impacts on the treble si
adjacent to the site and also further to
the north the two that i pointed out
earlier
but all other matters considered can be
adequately addressed and so officers are
working towards the approval of this
scheme if the air quality matters can be
addressed but obviously they are
matters which need to be taken with
seriousness
and obviously work together with natural
england to make sure we resolve them
so the recommendation is as on page 32
of the committee report to delegate
authority to the chief planning officer
to resolve the outstanding issues on the
planning application
thank you chair
thank you joe any questions for the
officer
david doesn't council blaspheme
thanks if you go back sorry to slide
38.
which is the materials
the slider
i guess that's at cgi have we got any
photographs of any buildings that have
got this
this covering to show what it's like in
real life rather than
um
i haven't included it in the
presentation
i don't have a way of putting it up on
the screen but uh we do we do have some
photos but obviously it's not within
this context of this application site
but um they do provide a very similar um
appearance to that shown on the screen
and we were given some examples of other
um uh times when this has been um been
used and they do look very similar to
what that cgi is so officers have
confidence so that cgi is representative
of
what the visual impact would be
okay so it's a proven technology as such
could you go to 31
now we're looking at the building
through this potash house
yeah it's not visible
but surely if we looked from potash
house the back garden of potash house
that would be really dominant wouldn't
it behind it that isn't the view from a
listed building as important as the view
to the listed building
and the impact on the setting um is
obviously it does it relates to a number
of matters it's how the enlisted
building
has kind of historically worked with the
landscape its relationship to the
landscape and also yes the experience of
the heritage assets so and there will be
an impact from um
the building being extended to that
heritage asset um but that's all been
taken account of um both the experience
when you're in the listed building and
also this viewpoint through when we've
made the heritage assessment that's set
out in the committee report
okay
thank you
councillor beer
um thank you mr chairman a couple of
questions um
slide 11
if you can get that up um
i think you said that was 40 meters 19
meters and 26.7 meters do you have
anything
as a slide that shows us
what's existent and this over imposed on
it so the difference in height
yes i thought that was the one
i mean how much more higher is it than
what's there there was some figures in
the report but i can't find it quickly
enough yeah
yeah so this is the taller building um
and we have
uh
broadly speaking i think 20 meters on
the existing building but then um there
are extensions across parts of it to go
up to 40 meters
in total
so how much haha is that that's what i
need to know between what's existing
yeah and what's going to end up with for
this building it's 20 meters for this
building it's 20 meters um and for
building b um it's it's about eight
meters in parks it's not so many
extensions to building
and the other one is totally new isn't
it yes and sees new yeah thank you um
in um
slide 36
which shows a view across the fields i
think it's from clemson i'm not sure
um
there was
some trees
that was nearly sort of the height look
there there's some trees in the in the
area which is nearly as tall to the
right as the proposed new building and i
dare say those trees are many many many
years old but there are trees that could
be planted perhaps through the quick
growing that could perhaps try and
obscure it a bit anyway um i suppose the
issue with this building is there are so
many viewpoints where the building would
be visible from it would be very
difficult to um kind of plant all of
those areas up and i think it's it's
it's perhaps an unavoidable um impact
that this will be visible to the wider
area this um this building um
i think um yeah there's obviously there
are quite a few trees already around the
site aren't there but it's those other
viewpoints as you'll see from this slide
down here there's obviously quite a few
viewpoints and it'll probably be and
also outside of control of the
applicant's land ownership to be able to
put planting in those areas and my final
point then mr chairman is um certainly
from glenster this is all downhill does
that site continue if i remember rightly
slightly runs down doesn't it towards
the old railway line or the river or
that whatever it is there yes yeah from
the road that's lower yeah even from the
road down to building gambie you can see
it on the slides i don't i can't quite
remember which slide it is now but yeah
there is a slight step um step down and
um the site is fairly level it just it
does slope towards the river valley um
at the bottom i think it's more than
slide it does go down all the way yeah
thank you
thank you
thanks
thank you chair um mine is to do the
same sort of thing i've got an ordnance
survey map here
and if you look from
up the 1066 which is the first entrance
up into clemson village crown moore hill
and around there were any of those
photographs taken from there was that on
um 37 on slide 37 where was that taken
from again um i agree with councillor
beer it's quite um
a slope down towards the side
yes yeah there's uh with that um
studies of uh the viewpoints around here
i'll see from a fair distance from the
site and yeah the
land is more elevated here you do get
views down to the river valley from
these public rights of way um public
right of way also one of the viewpoints
was taken from here um you do get views
from um all the way down to the
application site um and they do the
building will break the horizon
obviously within the wider landscape um
it's
a relatively small extent of built form
but obviously it is it is a built
formerly relatively in an undeveloped
area as well and so it does make the
visual impact all the more marked and as
the committee reports set out the
landscape harm does vary from
right up to high and significant and
from the different viewpoints
okay
come to the whole do you want to ask
yeah just one thing joe on slide 36
the red line
that's the total width of the
application site isn't it yeah it
doesn't illustrate the different levels
that there will be on the site so is
that red line that
the maximum height of a particular
section
of the proposal no it's just to show the
extent of the site as you say it won't
be a built form breaking horizon across
the whole of that area there will be the
40 meter component
which will be noticeable across part of
the site and also other buildings but it
won't be a full block across the whole
of that area but we mustn't take into
account that red line is a mess
okay thank you
but is there any way you can sort of
indicate where
the building is because up until then i
just assumed that whole site so that's
interesting that's the whole site it's
not actually the height the whole height
of the if you can show us where that is
roughly in there
um but it breaks the horizon um and so
it will be above the horizon but i don't
have a precise um kind of a line i can
show you and i don't want to mislead
members guessing at this point but it
will break the horizon um above the um
existing tree line that's not the whole
length that's the main thing thank you
thank you
okay council osborne sorry
thank you mr chairman um you know just a
very
quick one really on the recommendations
one and two what i'd like to know is
how long will the this development plan
uh and other material considerations
take um we you know i understand the
situations with the um with the heights
of buildings and of course obviously
with the uh pollution that might be
expected but
um really i would have i would have
liked to have seen this
you know
pushed forward
at a good rate
thank you thank you miss jim
and yes the applicants submitted
what we hope is the final report to
satisfy the concern of natural england
there have been um several meetings
between the air quality consultants and
planning officers and the
national england advisors as well to try
and bottom out precisely what
information is required
and we do have that final report in now
obviously we hope um that will address
the issues and we'll consult natural
england um and see where it takes us um
but we um we have been working closely
with the applicants to provide that
information um and working as quickly as
we can to try and resolve it
yeah thank you thank you for that and a
very good presentation but
what do you expect the time to take to
get this through as we stand at the
moment please
um if we have sufficient information now
um we'll have a few week consultation um
and uh there's a legal agreement to um
relating to the travel plan so we'd be
looking at a time scale of a few weeks
to um issue a consent but obviously i
just i am uncertain due to natural
incidence requirements it's slightly out
of our control as to what their response
would be and as i say we were consulting
i think yesterday on the revised
information so we're looking at a
three-week period to find out if that
addresses the um concerns
and
did you want to come and speak
thank you councillor mclaren
uh joe we've heard about the new biomass
building
which is going to take the shells
i like the presentation that really
clarified it for me but but
what is the
operation between
where the
um
is that building a
so how are the shells going to is there
a storage for the shells or what is it
is there some connection between
uh the main building and the biomass
building
yes i might just need to refer that um
question to the applicant who's present
today but my understanding is that can
there is a connection to feed the
biomass boiler from building a which
wasn't showing all the plans but um
there was a kind of um yeah kind of uh
conveyor belt and affected so our first
story yeah thank you joe thank you
thank you
well
the
applicant has indicated that he'll try
and answer your question after his
presentation
any more questions
no
thank you very much joe
right moving on
we don't have a representative from the
parish council or an objector or a
supporter the only public speaker have
is mr brian bowen
on behalf of the applicant right you
have three minutes to address the
committee
morning i'm brian boeing gm for gcb uk
previously the operations manager for
phillips event at this site and had the
responsibility to find a new owner
sourcing a company that would bring
employment to the area was a key
priority gcb met that criteria
gcb was formed in 1982 publicly listed
in 2005 but the majority is still owned
by the same family
gcb started purely as a coco commodity
trading company but now sourcing the
beans directly has become the company's
strength
gcb worked and formed farming
cooperatives to ensure consistent buying
pricing and helping the farmers invest
not just in their farms but in their
communities thus supporting them in the
long term and creating a robust
sustainable source for beings that has
become the backbone of the business
philosophy to be the world's most
preferred and leading sustainable cocoa
partner
the uk is the third largest importer of
chocolate in the world consuming 8.1 of
total chocolate demand valued at over
1.6 billion
the plan for the strategically decoded
glemson facility is to meet this market
gap producing cocoa liquor butter powder
and both solid and liquid chocolate
presently our competitors do not
manufacture been to bar in the uk
this will put us in a strong supply
chain position to both the well-known
brand names and being flexible enough to
meet the demands of the true
independence
uk import tariffs have been changed to
support this with the european 8 import
tariff being dropped to zero post brexit
giving us an immediate like for light
competitive costing position to do this
we will use our own beans
sugar from a name i'm sure you're aware
of embarrassing edmonds uk milk powder
and cocoa equivalents and flavorings
from haverhill
the process itself will use both
photovoltaic cells as well as the
biomass energy source powered from the
cocoa shell waste
for every ton of these shells we can
generate five and a half tons of
self-made steam which abates north point
ton of co2 and replaces 350 cubic meters
of natural gas usage
the investment plan is fully aligned
with the natural planning policy
framework and as can be seen within our
proposal shows a very significant
financial investment in this factory
that is 90 million plus of inward
investment which is privately funded
creating over 145 jobs during the
construction stages 370 permanent jobs
in a range of occupations which will
significantly address the loss of major
manufacturing from the babe area in
recent years and create 11.9 million
wage expenditure annually helping to
sustain local businesses and services in
summary gcb is a sustainably driven
business we have a robust business plan
to supply a market is presently
struggling to source product let alone
from a sustainable source and a
cost competitive position we want to
make suffolk at home not just a place of
work but integrate the community we want
to build a strong british market
position utilizing the suffolk brand
invests very significantly in both
buildings and equipment this is a
long-term investment which in turn means
long-term job security in a robust
marketplace produced in a sustainable
manner as working as well as looking
after our planet for the future thank
you very much questions please
um
who's the one who had a question but
earlier on
question
council mclaren for your question today
thank you chair
um
good morning
um can i just clarify
where the beans are coming from you said
our own beans can you tell me the
country of origin or is it in england
so you can only grow cocoa beans at 27
degrees either side of the equator
so these are going to be coming from the
ivory coast they're imported yes yeah
okay so to follow on with what i was
asking before
can you just tell me
how the operation is going to work so
presumably they're imported they come in
a container or something into the site
can you just take me through that
quickly that process so the first part
of it is what we do we dry and we
separate the bean from the shell and the
shell makes up between depending on the
beam type from 12 to 17 percent so then
we just have the outer part of it the
outer part of it is blown internally by
pipes into what will become the biomass
boiler then with the cocoa bean then
goes through the refining process okay
thank you thank you chair
thank you thank you for the presentation
and just a quick one um
reason why that you can't lower it
and is it only for one machine um why
you can't lower that bit in the ground
rather than high in the roof because the
impact on the whole countryside
um
have you got you know i know i said said
money but
is it that dramatic that
um
the first issue is that where we are as
a tape water level we have the store
behind us so if we start going down we
hit the water level so then we have
tanking problems it's very difficult to
go low so it is a challenge the actual
process itself works on gravity as well
as a drop in the product
so it's an efficiency use we'd have to
use more energy if we didn't go
vertically but also if you then have a
problem with the system it means you
have to take apart the whole system and
remove all the product that's in it so
you then be reducing waste rather than
good product
thank you
thank you mr chairman um a couple of
points um
firstly on
water
within our report it talks about
wastewater flows et cetera et cetera
but anglian waters say that there is no
they have no assets on the site
so
this wastewater that you're producing
where is it coming from and where would
it go to if it doesn't go to the
glensford waste treatment plant
we are joe mentioned that we're having
our own wastewater plant on site to make
sure that the water that we use will be
cleaned
from our water
yes
we talked about 370 net jobs across
the weber area but our report talks
about it being across the whole of the
east of england
i don't think we have other than hadley
made i don't think we've got any other
major chocolate manufacturers or
chocolate bar manufacturers in the in
the district
and 140 thing the containers of beans
are coming into where
and how are they again presumably then
come by truck to clemsford and the
chocolate goes out by truck correct
so we're creating quite a considerable
level of hgv movement into what is a
rural area
um i think within the plan that we've
submitted the actual movement of product
will be less than when we had the
philips event site
there
for the tonnage of product we're moving
because it's a very dense product the
amount of product that we're actually
moving comparison truck movements
right but the the we're not talking
about the events factory are we we're
talking about cocoa production and then
increasing volume of plant and
everything else on that side council i i
think you're stretching a point there
thank you
council beer you have a question
uh thank you mr chairman if i've got two
or three um
just follow along to 350 jobs
is that the maximum amount of jobs that
you'll be creating um
also
will the
building works
i understand that some of them will be
specialists i do accept that but will
the building works be
done by recruiting local builders where
possible
and
the long-term
outlook for the job market
um whilst it's important that we create
jobs for local people and we do want as
many local as possible
i think it's also important nowadays mr
chairman that we
also would look to you to be able to now
pay good wages because that is certainly
something that's coming out from central
government that
whilst we encourage
uh developments
we also got to encourage
local companies and you could be the
first here to pay better wages because
local people um you know it is a
depressed sort of whole area the whole
of our areas around here council waiting
for beer i think yeah i'm trying to get
you're stretching a bit on the planning
permission side well no that's the plan
wages it's a point
if i could respond yes certainly the uh
technology that we'll be utilizing at
the site um will give a broad spread of
occupations as i said in in my
presentation so the definitely intent is
to bring
and educate and share we've already been
in communication with the suffolk
university for postgraduate schemes
and how we will work previously um i'm a
stem ambassador so going into schools
explains them what we're going to do in
the local area and bring the areas is
it's the full intent to look immediately
for local employment
um my next question is follow on from
what councillor osborne
mentioned on time limit and i will be
putting it also to our in the debate but
to you sir
um will it be your intention
to get this up and running if we're
reminded to approve it as quickly as
possible uh what is your time frame
because quite often we can give a
permission here and then it drags on and
on and we don't want that
we we need this up and running if we
were minded to approve it as soon as
possible
i am very
motivated to do it as soon as possible
thank you chair yeah just um
uh carrying on from councillor owens
question really with regards to the
height of the uh of the unit 40 meters
um i mean that's a substantial building
130 over 130 feet um so
why does it have to be 40 meters well i
understand that it's about process but
can you just explain that why not 30
meters for example why wouldn't that
work if you can explain
the sheer capacity and the way we go
from the willowing process to the
refining process one sits on top of the
other so to do it in economic the volume
that we need to put through the business
if you imagine we have a silo which then
goes for a burning then through a
grinding then through a refining process
before we can then level it out and we
can step up for a further refining
process it's that pure stack that gives
the height
so we have looked into the market area
to see if there's any way to do it and
it's it's the economics of scale that
make us do it in that way it's a so we
saw an industry standard that is
constantly being challenged because to
build at height costs so if we could do
it lower we would it's just the most
economic way and we can run the plant in
that
are there manner
are there any other questions
this public speaker
no
thank you mr bowen actually wait there
in case there are some more questions
come up in the debate
no more questions then we'll move into
debate
um as is our custom councillor halt as a
ward member
um do you wish to open the debate or do
you want to save your comments for later
you're totally entitled to do either
i'll save my comments for later if
that's all right yeah that's fine i'll
do the same that's okay
fine
moving on can i open the debate who who
would who would like to kick off
camp severe you you for a change
alphabetical order
um yes uh we're going through this and
watching the slides that the officers
put up
um
it seems to me that
other than the height of the build and a
lot of it is already there i know
there's no additional bit
it is a site where there's been a lot of
activity over the years
and it has employed a lot of people as
i'm sure the local members are well
aware of and we all know
the local members in that whole area
know people who've worked there so i
think we have a good understanding of
the site
yes it is going to be taller but perhaps
this is a price we have to pay i i mean
at the end of the day
do we want it to stand there empty do we
want to have ongoing long
prolonged um discussions which are never
ending
and
i would hope that if we were minded to
approve this that the officers
would do everything in their power to
try and get this
underway
because it's no good if we decide we
want to go down the road of approval
if every little obstacle comes up and
whilst i'm not against delegating powers
to the chief planning officer
i would like to be assured by him that
if we were minded to approve it that
you know he will move this as quickly as
possible i know there are outside
elements that you have to deal with
which are outside your control
um but i i do feel that time is the
successes here that we do need to get on
with this
um
less hgv vehicles i mean that's got to
be a plus um
the the fact that we're creating work
for local people also got to be a plus
i really
can't see
where we
have to refuse this mr chairman so i
would be minded to go towards this but
i'll come back to that later if i may
thank you
did the
penny officer wanted to pass a comment
about
i'm there thank you chair um i think it
was actually in the end pointed at the
chief planning officer but i'll do my
best and he can he can clean up at the
end but but in effect i think you've hit
the nail on the head um
as did councillor osborne earlier in
that this is about expediency and i
think that officers have have judged
notwithstanding that we know that there
are some very and we've been very
transparent about this that there are
some quite serious harms posed
on the other side of the balance the
benefits are really quite considerable
and we recognize the commercial
imperative here
it's moving in a positive direction if
not for the ecological issue the quality
issue and in all likelihood we would be
recommending approval
um
that is an unknown at this present time
so we can't lawfully take a decision or
make a recommendation to you because we
don't know the extent or nature of the
impacts related to the air quality until
we get that final sign off for natural
england
but in effect what you'll be doing is
delegating
authority to the chief planning officer
down to the officers to get on with it
get it sorted
in accordance with our own policies
which tell us that we must work
proactively to find solutions to grant
permissions where possible um and that's
what we're seeking to to do in effect
and i think you wanted assurance from
the chief planning officer that we would
do
he's nodding so yeah that's that's what
this is about because
we could delay and wait and sort this
but that means we've got to come back to
committee we need to schedule you know
we could save weeks which actually makes
a huge amount of difference
thank you councillor busby you were
going to comment
yeah there are obviously a lot of
positives for this
there are one or two things that do
concern me though um i don't know we can
get the slides back up again slide 16.
this is going to be a large building the
current building is
acceptable from the road it's not
dominant
but if you're going to
more than triple the height of it in
places
and
it's the location to how close to the
road it's going to be if you've
potentially got a 40 meter building on
the side of the road that is very
dominant
and if you are i the concern is that one
of the benefits that we're talking about
is the material that's going to reflect
what's around it
but that's got to be a danger for road
users hasn't it if you're driving along
that road and you'll get a your own
lights reflected back to you i mean
we've all remembered
um
james bond
in goldfinger
i don't think we want to um be offering
that as a solution
uh so whilst it does seem like it's a
good idea
how safe is that going to be
for road users
joe would you like jeff
yes um yeah the um the aspect of the
site um is such that so sunlight would
probably be the biggest um concern for
dazzling um road users and such like i
think the lights from car vehicles
wouldn't be um they'd be directed
towards the road often so they wouldn't
be directed at the building but the um
aspect of the building obviously um the
sun would travel kind of from the east
side round to the south so the
reflective light um any effective light
would be to the south of the site but um
my um my understanding of the um
the materials and well obviously um
that the although it reflects the light
it doesn't reflect the um kind of it
doesn't dazzle the light it doesn't
redirect the sunlight down towards any
kind of certainly any roads due to the
positioning of them and traveling east
to west so that hasn't been a concern um
that we um that would marry us wanting
to change that material
and um
the other thing is i am concerned about
the view from that from potash cottages
from
from there
out of the back
i don't know how close it is because
somebody can tell me how close
the
cottage is to the site um
can i
i remember to help you there i i i think
it's nearly half a mile isn't it
and
and so to a certain extent you get into
the back garden into the orchard and you
won't see a thing
a little bit of local knowledge sorry
i'm using that
council mclaren you wanted to make a
comment uh yes i just want to um i'm i'm
very sort of impressed with the
um mr bowen explained the process and
the operation
it sounds to me as it's economically as
efficient as it can be in a process
producing chocolate
so i i think that is commendable for our
area
and i
like counsellor beer
i i would support the
the recommendation because
um
we need the um
employment we need something to
promote our
suffolk and weber district council and
i'm i'm all for it thank
thank you councillor parker
yeah thank you um probably a question
for for chief planning officer if if i
can but um while sparse councillors are
rightly um seemingly focusing on the um
you know the architectural impact of the
um
of the property the building um a lot of
the locals that sit on the committee
will uh remember only too well the
former bush boat allen
site from from years ago which is
literally only a stone's throw away as
the crow flies which used to belch out
all manner of
fumes and um
cheese and onion crisp flavors across
the across the valley so i'm heartened
that it'll now be a chocolate um odor
that's that's coming across the valley
but
there is an accompanying report um in
the table papers a very technical uh
report which i would suggest is perhaps
beyond the technical capabilities of of
most of the members on the committee um
so what assurance can be given um that
that that report is uh within you know
tolerances and and is acceptable to the
local community
um so so in effect those emission
impacts relate more to actually the
triple s i rather than human health so
this is about
eco toxicology
in effect and this has followed and i
think joe has mentioned this has gone
through a sort of an iterative process
where natural england have been setting
out what it is that they they need to
have that assurance that there won't be
adverse impacts on the triple si or both
triple sis
um and as of yesterday we've had what is
hopefully the final report from the
applicant
showing um what those sort of loadings
are and what the impacts are likely to
be
and i think
in honesty in the time available i
haven't looked at it in great detail but
it seems to suggest that
there wouldn't be an adverse impact um
but obviously we will we will look for
natural englands as we are required to
do look for their final guidance on that
point um and once we know what the
impacts are as officers we're capable of
capable of then of undertaking the
planning balance and potential then
granting permission if there is an issue
you'll note from the recommendation that
if we're given pause for thought we'll
come back and let you know so that you
can undertake that balance and decide if
there are harms to the triple s i
because typically you would not grant
planning permission in those
circumstances you'd have to weigh that
up against the benefits and
better your shoulders than ours i think
in that regard
yes mr chairman i would like to
so we can move on and allow the local
members to comment i'd like to move um a
recommendation that we approved this
plan and application
because the benefits definitely in my
opinion outweigh the harm that it may do
and
by saying that
yes we have to be relevant we have to
listen to the other people that we've
consulted but
i would say to the officers here and now
that
i'm of the opinion that
this should go ahead and i would like
you to move
as quickly and as efficiently as
possible uh to get uh to carry out those
wishes
understanding that there may be some
concerns but
you're there to solve these and that's
what i would hope you'd do rather than
come back to us thank you mr chairman so
you're asking for a second though your
proposal is for the as as it stands yes
thank you very much i wasn't the officer
councillors
is that we're not in a position to
approve today that's right isn't it
i did not suggest that the officer's
recommendation i particularly chose my
words it's they're not recommended
anything
well i think we ought to hear from the
chief planning officer
one moment thanks
one two questions for me um the
recommendation before you is for a
delegation
um
and so effectively the the vote would be
uh around the delegation set out in one
and two
uh as as officers we can't in all
conscience recommend that you formally
determine the application today because
you don't have enough information to
draw that conclusion
this is about effectively you are you're
indicating that you are as a committee
minded to approve it
and you know as as strongly as you have
indicated uh wish that to happen
but we as officers have to advise you
that the technical information the last
pieces of the jigsaw are not in place
and it would be unreasonable for you to
conclude it much as it's unreasonable
for us to recommend that you
actually grant permission on this basis
and therefore in order to push this
along with all jew haste as you want the
recommendation is a delegation
that we
resolve all of these things and my
expectation from here
is to
ask a case officer and
mr stroud to effectively establish a
timetable as promptly as possible with
the applicant to work out conditions
obligations and all of those things that
can be moved ahead on without prejudice
basis while we're still sorting this
emission question out
thank you jim exactly what i was saying
mr chairman thank you
thank you for putting words in
councillor bismarck um
a second uh
councilors would you wouldn't do us to
say anything at this day
you totally agree
any more comments from members
if not can i invite oh sorry can should
we do council hidden first and then
council osborne sorry i'm getting i
don't know what i'm doing today
thank you uh mr chairman i'd just like
to bear out exactly what has been spoken
about this
this morning in terms of the
position off of that chocolate factory
uh and i'm sure that um
the applicant has obviously looked at uh
stuff like bornville and cadbury's up in
in liverpool so he knows exactly where
the position is with that but
i'm i'm also
wanting to
see the
skilled work back into an area which
we've lost over lots of years now
and might i'll just add to council
parker you don't have to go as far as
that one with fish with chips and onions
and that you've only got to go to
somewhere a bit nearer to us both and
that is on the
roundabout
at sudbury so
i hesitate to give the name of the firm
but
it's been looked at
every month now
for several years by the environmental
environmental control
and
to my knowledge
and to the paperwork i have they have
spent millions on getting that they
problems with the uh
the stench as it was called in sudbury
uh down to a level which was acceptable
and they've and they've managed that
thank you
thank you guys
answer holt
your time has come
well i've done about that just a couple
of things read the materials joe
they're very nice very shiny um is there
a long-term plan to keep them that way
because i know cladding on buildings
does deteriorate over time and it does
take a specialist team to keep them
clean and if they're being designed and
used in that way to reflect
the light i hope that there's a plan in
place to keep them you know
clean so that they do their job
um another thing i just want to comment
really about um from a glimpser point of
view um historically we've had a
heritage of industrial usage within the
village and the surrounding area
and and speaking on behalf of i think of
the residents um
they're very excited that this factory
will be brought back into use and that
employment can again be obtained for
people within the village
who through generations have been
employed down at that site
so i think from that point of view i'm
sure the residents of glensa would
appreciate this factory coming forward
um
that's all i really want to say but if i
could have some sort of clarification on
the the cleanliness of the cladding for
its uh use
yes thank you council hold um yeah we
have recommended the planning condition
to uh look at the ongoing management
maintenance of that material to make
sure it does stay and functions in its
reflective form in perpetuity so that's
like which we would go through um
planning consent with but
the applicants i think would also um
have expressed their desire to be a
considerate employee and consider it um
kind of occupant of the site as well so
we have assurances from them they would
want to make their site look as visually
appeasing as possible too
so yes we feel that is covered
thank you joe and i with my own comments
as a resident of graham said yes we are
looking forward to the
factory reopening
and as michael said we have a history of
industrial development within the
village coming from making silk making
coconut mats
and and moving on until making stuff for
babies with we're now getting into the
stage where perhaps it's of more
interest to those of a certain age but
i'm not a chocolate lover so
to non-interest i think
do that counselor buzz we want to say
something well taking that point can i
just be sure that the the enthusiasm
shown by the members is not because of
the product
um i mean would they be that keen if it
was a semiliner
factory
i
i don't think you're going to get an
answer to that kentucky
okay if there's no more comments we have
a proposal
can i ask the officer to conduct a vote
thank you chair members of that vote is
now in progress in your modgult
okay thank you can i take your vote
verbally
um
i recommend
approval
thank you
thank you chair that's nine votes for
ten vote score and one abstention ten
votes wrong and one percent
thank you everyone
we've got there we got let's go we'll
wish you all the best for the new
factory and
thank you um can i suggest that we have
a break now and we resume at
just before 11 o'clock to make sure you
all are here by 11.
welcome welcome back everyone we have a
slight delay we're still waiting the
member from long enough for parish
council to turn up but
we can't carry on without we can carry
on without him at this particular stage
moving on to dc 21 02319 land to the
east of station road along melford
um
i will now ask case of the principal to
present this application
to the committee thank you thank you
chair good morning members and guests
as the chair said this is a
an application that's coming back to you
from the meeting of the 14th of july
where you asked us to look into a number
of matters my role this morning is to
feedback and update you on
progress that has been made
to resolve all the issues that you
highlighted
just to remind members this application
is in two parts
first part is the actual reserved
matters everything except access access
was previously agreed at outline stage
and we're also looking at the discharge
of a number of conditions that was
attached to the
outline planning permission
just to familiarize yourselves with the
site it is to the south of the main body
of
long milford
just off the b1064
rugbridge hill
just to remind you that
a package of section 106
mitigation was secured
at outline stage that included
affordable housing at 35
early years site
early years financial contributions
footpath contributions
including new footways to the road
frontage bus stop improvements and
transfer of open space
to a management company but with full
public
access so today we won't be looking at
anything to do with the 106 or i don't
intend to as that has already been
secured
just to give you a very quick fly
through just to familiarize yourself
with the context
so we're
traveling northwards
and the yellow arrows are pointing out
on the right where we are in terms of
that drawing we're just coming up to the
site
which is on the right and you'll just
see in a minute
an illustration pop up
that access has already been approved
so the site extends to the east
to the edge of that green field the
darker green field
and then we travel further northwards
and eventually
you reach the edge of what we might call
historic core of long melford so there's
quite a lot of intervening
modern development before you get to the
historic core of long milford
so the amendments you asked us to look
at i will now
report back on one by one
so there's the list we'll start with the
appearance of the gateway element to the
site the buildings at the gateway and
we'll work our way through that that
list
just to remind members as i say the
access has been approved but it does
include extensive sections of
footway north and south linking this
site to existing
sections of footway
that run on the east side of the
1064.
so that's that shows you
uh the extent of footway that will be
delivered going northwards and it will
connect to the existing path at
southgate gardens
and to the south there's a shorter
section that will connect to the
existing path on rugbridge hill
so members will recall that your first
concern was that area of brown in the
bottom right hand corner the first
glimpse you get of this development as
you enter the estate members felt that
it needed
uh particular attention to better
reflect the traditional character of
long melford albeit this is a new estate
on the periphery of long milford
i think there was universal feeling
amongst members that
this could be redesigned to better
reflect their character so
that's the view that you were most
concerned about
so on the left is the layout that you
saw on the 14th of july on the right
is
what we have worked
together with bloor to come up with an
i think a much enhanced
uh prospect so without further ado
that's what we were looking at
14th of july and i think we would all
agree that that is perhaps a typical
modern estate but you were looking for
something with
far more elaine far more production
something that better reflected long
alfred so
what we have come up with is
that
so you see we've got a lot more
connected buildings we've got
timber archways we've got
a more
village character development and we
have been successful in
encouraging
bloor to deliver some flint
units which is something all the
committee felt was appropriate i think
you referred to a similar development in
braintree well we have managed to secure
flint you'll notice that even the wall
at the front where there wasn't a wall
before is a flint and brick wall
so in terms of
the detailing we've got clay plain tiles
we've got slate we've got flint we've
got traditional red
soft red bricks
boarding
bell drips in the render pentas boards
very simple canopies nothing too
elaborate
so what you end up with is something
looks
like that
which we feel
is
significantly better than
what you had before and it's something
that as officers i would be proud to say
we have secured that so in many ways
you put some steel into our backbone and
we went back to bloor to say let's try
harder
i know that council busby and others
were particularly
concerned that we had this mock tudor
boarding that's all gone
so if we look at what that means is
that's what it looked like previously
they've all gone throughout the whole
estate and we have something
far simpler
in terms of the mix i know there was a
very strong feeling amongst the
committee and the parish council
i think it was councillor beer who
wanted
fewer four bed larger units and
more of the middle size smaller middle
size
we have secured a significant reduction
in the four bed number of four bed units
they've gone down by
eleven
and there's now an emphasis on two and
three bed
units
there was also a very strong feeling
that we should encourage the use of
the suffolk pink render there wasn't any
in the scheme before
we do have that
agreement from the applicant so we could
have various shades through from the the
lighter pinks through to the
what traditionally might be thought of
of the bigger ox blood
red colour
although that might just be myth in the
old days it might have been crushed
burnt brick and burnt clay that was used
to create that colour
but we certainly now have that in the
palette
another area that members were very
concerned about was
the raised tables and i think it was a
general feeling that it was far too
harsh
far too urban
for long milford because the whole of
that area in light grey
was intended to be pavias and i think if
you remember they were grey and i think
members felt it was particularly somber
and needed to be one
warmed up in terms of the color but also
get some planting in to create a far
more
natural
effect i think there was some members
were concerned there might be confusion
as to what bits of that
table
were for pedestrians what was for cars
how would it work
so we've worked with blood to
deliver what you've asked for in many
ways and i think it has helped
it become much clearer
to drivers and pedestrians where they
should be and also it has significantly
softened
the character of that area
so that is what he's now proposed and
you'll see significant areas of
planting we're also using a much richer
red brown behavior
than the somber gray
so in terms of that's what it was before
effectively
and i quite understand why you thought
that was very urban and harsh but
effectively what's happened is
that
and i think you were looking for a far
more traditional arrangement where front
gardens
were what confronted the
passer by rather than
hard
paving
there was also considerable concern that
each of those colored circles represent
a turning head and i think members felt
that having so many turning heads on the
edge of the site perhaps suggested
something sinister that might come later
but in truth
as you all know what you have to
consider is the application before you
but we've thought about it how can we
give you additional comfort and it's
interesting to note that those turning
heads are a significant distance from
the site boundary so i've set them out
on that screen in some places they're
over 18 meters distant
between the
closest edge of the turning head to the
edge of the site
but what we've suggested i think it was
raised before
is each of those turning heads will be
planted
with extra heavy standard
trees and in the report i've given you
an indication of
just how
majestic
an extra heavy standard tree can be
so
that's one typical
example of the landscaping around parts
of those turning heads
so just to help you
so the triangles are showing you
where on the plan
that is
so there's the footpath that runs the
whole the red triangle is the whole way
around the
development giving you a recreational
trail with only one road to to cross
but that
i think should allow your fears that
you're going to have a turning head
right up against the edge of the site
there will be extensive
belts of landscaping around the whole of
this development so when you see it from
the countryside view your
view of those houses will be filtered
through
landscaping
so
that's the view we've actually now got
the fencing that some of you
preferred
more traditional
farmland
edge oh
let's go back one
so that's
effectively those trees are of a height
10 to 12 meters that you would get with
an extra heavy standard so if i can just
go back
you get that
sorry
that is what you get almost instantly
with that development now obviously an
extra heavy standard takes a bit more
management and care because those trees
will be thirsty and i'm
confident that we will have a landscape
management plan
that will ensure that those trees are
properly watered for at least five years
and cared for so that they can thrive
so we instantly get
an end stop to that
that view
there was also a very strong feeling
that we had a fantastic opportunity to
create
enhanced biodiversity
and improve habitats
members were particularly keen to see
wildflower meadows
so i can confirm that
the cross-hatched areas in each of these
will be
wildflower meadow
and on the left
is the species that will be in the mix
we know that because it is a particular
mix from a particular supplier
so there'll be a very rich mixture of
wild flowers
so again all around the site very strong
belts of wildflower so we should get
lots of butterflies we should get lots
of wildlife
in and amongst those areas
members are also concerned that the
large areas of open space the green on
that drawing because they'll be
managed by a management company that was
all agreed at outline stage
would the public be able to enjoy those
spaces or might there be a risk that the
residents of this estate or their
management company try to exclude
the community the wider community from
these areas well as i've set out in the
report the section 106 effectively
requires that land to be open to
everyone
so the benefit with a management company
in crude terms is that
it isn't the public person that is
maintaining those areas but the public
have free right of access to all of them
and that includes the play area
i've
also whilst it's not a matter for this
reserved matters i do want to touch on
lighting because i know members becoming
increasingly concerned
about the impact of of lighting in rural
areas
condition eight which is not part of
this submission
requires the submission of a lighting
scheme particularly to ensure that we do
not harm
ecology
that will be a matter that comes to us
later
but it prompted me to look at this is
from cbre
the lighting diagram
for long milford and as you can see the
darker colors are
where
illumination is at its
lowest
during the evening and you can see that
sudbury has high levels high intensity
lighting which you might expect in a in
a big town or big town suffolk
in the core of sudbury but long milford
is actually really quite dark around the
edges
this site is on the edge of long melford
so we will be looking to agree a
particularly sensitive scheme
we don't want to see lots of sky glow we
want to see led lights if we have to
have lights at all so we are very
conscious that we need to
protect the sky environment really
around
normal melford so i just wanted that
slide to start to explain some of our
thinking so you could be assured that we
are
thinking about all of these things as we
go forward
i also wanted to point out that
long milford
will secure
community infrastructure levy receipts
in its own right
as soon as the
neighborhood plan for long milford is
adopted if this site hasn't commenced
they may well be entitled to a 25
percent
contribution
by right
from the total
secured but they will certainly be
entitled to 15 percent
and as you can see from the
workings out and they are very general
but there are based on the council's own
figures
there are significant sums potentially
that would be
secured
by the parish council
irrespective of what may be available
from the district council's sealed fund
and you will recall there were certain
discussions previously about
potential delivery of a crossing well we
did say before that that wasn't a matter
that you could secure through this
reserved matters application but i just
point out potentially there are funds
from other sources that the parish
council could begin to think about using
for themselves to deliver infrastructure
that they feel
is needed by the community
we'll skip that because that just comes
up with some figures but it's it's
significant
potentially the other point that members
wanted us to push was
energy conservation
and
law have agreed to up
the green energy conservation
credentials of the scheme up to 19
when you saw this last time it came to
you at 10 which is our current policy so
they were absolutely on target for your
adopted policy
but having
regard to comments that were made by the
committee law have
voluntarily upped that to 19
which is your
emerging policy
so what they have done is they've jumped
before they were pushed and they've
offered to
improve that and i'm sure our guest from
bloor can explain how they will achieve
that
but again that is a significant
improvement and enhancement to the
scheme that you saw in july
effectively we will have secured 100
electric vehicle charging
or at least capacity to accommodate
electric vehicle charging and only
today what was it yesterday i heard on
radio 4 that for the first time ever
electric vehicle sales have now
exceeded petrol and diesel for the first
time
on a month-by-month basis so there is no
doubt that electric vehicles are
are on their way and blower have
safeguarded future proof this by
effectively having 100 percent
capacity to to accommodate charging
we have managed to secure
at least 26 of the dwellings will have
pv panels and again that's an
enhancement from
what was on offer on the 14th of
july so again
laura making some
significant steps forward in terms of
helping the council to
deal with climate change and i'm hoping
that if bloor can do it other developers
can do it and we set a new benchmark for
delivery of
of
energy conservation technology
society is very well connected
to existing public rights
of way
as you can see the whole north east and
northwest corners are completely
well connected by pedestrian cycle
friendly networks which link into
long milford
and again the red is a perimeter
track
and there are connections from the
existing public rights away into that
extensive
new network of
footpaths
so you will be able to walk and cycle
from the site right into the heart of
long milford
so you would come out at this point
which is roman road onto the large green
swards
traveling along you have footpath
connections all the way into the heart
of
long milford
you will recall that this site also
included
a little feature on the corner
that is a world war ii mortar spigot
that will be turned into a little bit of
a feature with a seating area
and if you remember what a spigot mortar
was
effectively that's what it was and you
could rotate the mortar
too far at a 360 degree
angle so that's a nice reminder of part
of the heritage of
malford from the second world war
so what we are suggesting to members is
as we did previously
that
the reserve matters be approved and i
think it's fair to say that we have
secured through your
energies
an enhanced scheme from the one that we
saw on the 14th of july we are also
suggesting in terms of conditions
that some are already in a position to
be discharged because
all our consultees are happy with them
there are a few others where we just
need a little bit more
information and input
we have those with us but we haven't
necessarily had the full chance to
consult with our colleagues in other
services so we're suggesting that the
chief planning officer has the ability
to deal with those
conditions
by way of delegated authority but the
principle here is that the reserve
matters are now
better than they were in the 14th of
july and we continue to recommend them
and commend them to you thank you
thank you vincent
i thought any questions for the officer
councillor hinton
just a quick one on the last slide
what actually are the conditions that
have not still to be sorted out
yeah thank you very good point council
hinted
with the assistance of my colleague we
will fly back to the beginning and i'll
run quickly run through them
it's probably about number
nearer the front
bit more that's it
one one above that
brilliant
so
the ones that we are suggesting we are
now comfortable with are condition five
the open market housing mix and you
recall i've just said that we've
improved the number of two and three
betters
biodiversity enhancement strategy that's
one that we
feel is
not able to be
finalized today but we have got
additional material that we're
consulting with our
ecology specialists
on the construction management plan
that's something that we're still
working on we've had an amended
construction management plan
so that's
one of the ones we are suggesting we
need a bit more time to deal with we're
also suggesting we need a little bit
more time to deal with the construction
environmental management plan
and that's the bit about how is the site
managed during construction to avoid
pollution so that's in many ways very
similar to the previous one that's
something we're working on
we are satisfied with the surface water
management plan
we have got additional information on
noise and vibration so that's something
we can't deal with today
in terms of surface water energy
assessment archaeology
and the scheme to direct existing high
voltage overhead lines we are happy with
so out of that list it is conditions
nine
sorry seven
9
10 and 13
where the chief planning officer and
ourselves will need a little bit more
time but everything else we are
satisfied with
council of beer thank you mr chairman it
is on condition nine and you may have
touched on it but can you just
clarify or confirm as to how
strong that management plan will be
because quite often when these estates
are built
uh
three four years down the road not
necessarily valued
some of the um
woodwork posts and
the the bits that you put in for the
management to look after
get badly uh destroyed fall down knocked
down what have you how strong is that
that the management committee will be
able to solve these because we know on
other estates
um we complain about it to you we send
emails to the chief planning officer
asking them to look into this and find
them to get the
sorted and really it takes over a very
long time or it doesn't get done so how
strong is that strength please
that control
thank you councillor beer two elements
what we're looking at here is not
necessarily the management of the hard
landscaping the sort of knee rail
fencing it's actually the site during
construction
so what we're looking at in terms of
that condition is are things like
haulage routes how will materials get in
where will the compound be
what are the construction hours how will
the roads be swept to avoid mud
will there be
piling etc etc so in a sense we're just
making sure that the construction
activity causes as little disruption to
existing residents as possible but in
terms of the point that you make and
it's a it's a point that's well made is
the landscape management plan will
provide the details as to what happens
when some of the fencing deteriorates
what would the cutting regime brigane
that sounds a bit southern regime b in
terms of if we're looking at wildflower
meadow we're not talking about having it
cut every
so many weeks it's a light touch
regime in order to encourage the
plants to grow what will happen in terms
of watering the plants and managing so
that's something separate
on both of them we will monitor that
very carefully as you know
if it does become an enforcement matter
that will take its own course but what
i'm hoping is
you will recall that at the last meeting
you urged bloor to work closely with the
parish council
and i'm sure our guests will be able to
report on whether or not they've already
implemented some of that process of
working closely and keeping a strong
liaison but if it works properly
we ought to be involved so much because
local people will be able to use that
forum
and say we've got a real issue with
construction at number five it's causing
problems mrs miggins and through that
system council email vc and the
david on the parish council will be able
to speak directly to alex and say get
this sorted please and in many ways
that's a much better way to operate than
having to get the heavy guns of simon
bailey and you may want to ask both the
parish council and law whether they
think that system has already been set
up and is it if it has is it working and
if not why not
mr chairman yeah that was on the second
part rather than the first part that's
usually short-lived and that's in
control um but just following on from
that second part my question to you is
um and i can't remember but like brick
walls built beside
garage blocks and what have you that are
not in the ownership of that particular
um occupant they fall down and nobody
wants to be responsible to rebuild that
wall seven eight years after the site's
been built and we've had that in
glensfield cornard and sudbury
and that is a problem so
that's why i'm really concerned what
you've said most like the parish council
and the local members can sort out but
something like that doesn't need
we need perhaps not to build those where
nobody owns them perhaps thank you can i
just suggest through you chairs in
answer to that is that might be
something you want to put to our
guests because obviously they will look
to
convey all of those features
to prospective
purchases or the management company but
i understand the point you're making
the public purse doesn't necessarily
want to pick up the cost for that
thank you councillor jensen
thank you jeff uh sorry vince if i
missed this but you mentioned that i
think
um condition eight relating to the
lighting
has that been discharged because i can't
see that on the report anywhere
no that's something for us to deal with
so that's not all right so it's still
ongoing is it
counter rails
thank you chair thank you vincent um
just a query about um the piling because
we've had a real problem in sudbury in a
small area
with the noise level i think there are
49
drilling holes in one small area do we
have any indication of how much of that
will be done because that is very noisy
the indication is that there will be no
piling so if in the
construction management plan it says no
piling
that's what we'll expect
um
elsewhere when we know there's piling
then we can have all sorts of regimes to
control it but with the best will in the
world
if filing is necessary there has to be
some element of disturbance but
fortunately and we'll ask um
our guests to confirm in this case there
is no
piling required
thank you any more questions for the
officer
counselor busby
thank you uh can you mention condition
24
to direct existing high voltage
overhead lines can you show me
whereabouts today either a were and b
are now
if we could go to
almost the last slide
the one with the spigot
hoping that in that drawing you'll see
the poles
that's it
the two poles that you can see behind
the
family that are sitting on the bench
they run in
across the
the site
and on the edge of that site
once the closest opportunity
of a house to though to the line well
the talk is about
undergrounding
oh they are going underground that's
that's what we're looking to try and
achieve yes
okay thank you
thank you any more questions from
vincent
no thank you michael vincent
we now have the public speakers
i'll now ask representative parish
council
mr david watts to address the committee
you have three minutes mr watts to ex to
address the committee
can you hear me we can hear you yeah
thank you
um thanks very much
to laura holmes answered bayvo district
council planning department for
consulting the parish council as part of
the planning application process we much
appreciate the efforts they've gone to
and the changes they've made as a result
but we still have some important
reservations about the current
application law have now introduced two
flint houses and walls to add to the
variety of materials and to fit in with
long melford's rural feel that's welcome
but two out of 150 is not enough it
amounts to 1.3 percent of the total
number of homes you will see on page 78
of the office's report
that we suggested four more flint homes
in prominent positions overlooked by the
milford walk nature reserve and another
well-used footpath
a mere two flint houses is tokenism and
the number needs to be increased
on page 93 of the office's report it
says the level of two and
three-bedroomed open market homes is now
very close to the figure put forward by
bdc's strategic housing experts but this
obscures the fact that the number of
two-bedroom homes is well below the
strategic housing requirement and the
number of three bedroom homes is
slightly above
as we said on page 77 of the office's
report the number of two-bedroom homes
is now 26
that compares with the strategic housing
requirement of 36
or 48 percent if you include one
bedroomed homes of which there are none
in the development
last week i talked to milfa's leading
estate agent david burr
and they said there was a huge demand in
melford for two-bedroom homes by
first-time buyers
those available in station road near to
the site sell light hotcakes
we'd like to see more two-bedroom homes
to attract much-needed younger people
than first-time buyers along melford
finally
bloor has agreed consid continued
consultation with long alpha parish
council during the building phase this
is very welcome and necessary and we'd
like to see it made a condition of the
planning commission uh it hasn't got off
to a good start though when they started
to build the access road they installed
traffic lights and no parking signs
outside people's houses with very little
or no notice to
to effective residents or the parish
council they also knocked down the wall
of an adjacent bungalow and did work
work in the garden without the owner's
permission not a good start
so i i'd like it a condition of the
planet commission that the liaison takes
place all through the building between
bloor and the parish council thank you
very much
thank you mr watts would you stay there
and answer any questions from
members of the committee any questions
mr watt
no
and thank you very much
we have no other
objector or supporter so we now move to
the agent and i understand alex clark is
addressing us and mr james bailey and
colleagues are here to assist
when i asked you
to address the committee you have
five men that's three minutes thank you
chad
well good morning good morning everybody
members my name is alex clark i'm the
design and technical director at bloor
homes
i've been actively involved in the
application here at station road along
melford
i'm joined this morning as the chair
said by stephen lee our architectural
manager and james bailey
our planner and i'm sure we'll be able
to answer any questions you have for us
described in detail from the officers
report we firmly believe that
significant process uh progress has been
made with the scheme since the last time
that we met with members in july
as outlined we've reduced the number of
four bedroom properties by in excess of
20
there have been a number of design
changes made to the layout and there has
been an increase in sustainable measures
being proposed across the site
in addition to improved housing mix
there has been a number of design
improvements made
significant enhancements have been made
to the properties at the entrance
including architectural detailing and
materials
including flint dwellings and features
have also been introduced
the principal raised table now
incorporates the green spaces and
heritage bollards
all of the tudor boarding has been
removed
there is now more coloured render
including the suffolk pink as described
by the officer along with a wide range
of quality bricks and tiles
different coloured windows plinths and
boarding is now also being proposed
extra heavy trees are also added to the
ends of turning heads as outlined on the
officer's report
in terms of sustainability the scheme
now offers an improved carbon reduction
from 10 percent as set out in the
outlying planning conditions and current
policy
to 19
as set out in the council's emerging
policy
butts are also to be added to all plots
electrical vehicle charging provision
has been increased and pvs are continued
photovoltaics are continued to be
provided
these changes have come about as a
direct result of working closely and
building a relationship not only with
the district council but with the parish
council as well
a number of meetings have taken place
since july and we have been supplemented
by further phone calls and email
correspondence and we believe that a
collaborative working arrangement has
resulted in the current scheme you see
before you
we would propose that this would
continue well into the build stage and
beyond
this has only been possible with the
willingness to cooperate between all
parties and i would hope that everyone
would agree including parish members
that
the improved relationship has resulted
to confirm there remains no objections
from any statutory council tease the
site is recommended by the officers and
the site continues to be identified as
housing allocation in the emerging joint
local plan
this is a reserved matters application
which is seeking to confirm the details
of such
the existing outline consent has already
been established that the principle of
development is acceptable in this
location
with the changes that have been made
through the positive engagement with
both officers in the parish i am
confident that the areas identified by
members of the 14th of july committee
have now been properly discussed and
where possible negotiated into the
scheme thank you your time thank you sir
any questions please thanks for watching
oh yeah thank you
um
just um
will you take on an account what the
parish has said about
um
informing people
in giving them enough notice of things
that you do please yeah and i'm sure
that
hopefully the ward member will will
confirm that since uh
the 14th is the last committee so we've
had a number of meetings with them
number of emails i speak to the ward
council regularly near enough once a
week
personally and again we would expect
that that to continue right the way
through including my involvement in that
and yes
and um the trees
they look quite close to the buildings
what have you got
um because i'm very
aware of what it can do to paths and
whatnot once the roots come out yeah
are you
are you going to make sure so there will
be root barriers etc as per standard
details here that's brilliant thank you
thank you council jameson
thank you just a couple of questions
your carbon mission targets are
improving from 10 to 19 so what are you
doing for the extra 9
so on on the extra nine percent will be
additional pvs which have been
identified on the on the system um
in terms of what we do is a as a
standard we obviously
have a increased fabric
so increased insulation uh better air
tightness as well to add to that
the sat rating and eventually the epc
rating of that but predominantly it's
through additional pbs
so why are you only going for 39
drillings with
pvs
so the way that it we work we work out
um
the the usage is that we
start with the fabric first so the
increase in insulation the increase in
egg air tightness of the property um and
then we work out to get to a target and
energy improvement so to get to that 19
is that that effectively then works out
the 39 units
so so you only put in pv
arrays on 39 dwellings
that that's correct is that
so say so why only the 39 why not
go for more
so to hit a
tarp to hit that target the emerging
policy targets it's it's a calculation
based on right but
as i say we start with an improved
um insulation and
air tightness in order to achieve that
first
um also on this you're still going with
the gas boilers
are you including thermal storage on the
gas boilers
so you're right we are going
remaining with with gas boilers what we
are doing is we're providing a hydrogen
conversion kits with those gas boilers
so that boilers will be future-proofed
um should hydrogen be the the choice of
replacement of natural gas because i've
seen the report it's government report
it's a few years old now so it might be
out of date but it says if you include
the thermal storage on the flue gas
recovery it improves
both the
cost price cost savings for the resident
and the
carbon emitted quite a lot i mean have
you not considered using thermal storage
if that's
again this is something that we refer to
our sustainability experts to advise us
that what the
not only what the most economical for
ourselves but also for the end user will
will be
and as i say the what they've suggested
to us which is within the report is is
to go the way that we've gone to get
that 19
but also then
have a hydrogen conversion kit that
would allow future proofing at a later
stage so would you give residents or
prospective residents the opportunity to
choose air source seat pumps or
something else over the gas or is going
to be installed as standard but for this
for this site that gas will be installed
um
what we have worked with the offices on
and something that we as a business are
contemplating is offering additional pv
as a as an optional extra
for for customers so they themselves can
make that choice
okay thanks thanks
thank you
thanks for being here
thank you mr chairman um well first of
all i'd just like to take the
opportunity to thank you for this that
was very helpful very informative
it was excellent and also for taking on
board what the members and members of
the planning committee did list a lot of
these problems as they saw them and in
my opinion you've taken a lot of them on
board
the one part i would just like to
question you on
you heard me make the comments about the
management plan
we don't really want to end up where we
have to get the chief planning officer
to get the enforcement people out to
solve these problems and i accept the
parish council and the local member will
do their bit but again
it does cause problems
to the residents and particularly we've
got a situation where there's a garage
block and i don't know if there is any
garage blocks there but where there's a
brick wall built
and it belongs to nobody and it falls
down
five six years later and nobody wants to
pay to rebuild it and the parish council
don't want to take responsibility which
i can understand so it's that sort of
him and how strong is
uh you demand and from these management
uh companies that they do turn up and
replant the trees that have died that
the hedges that have
not come through and the fencing that's
like falling down thank you
thank you for that um
a
couple of things to to to mention about
that just we've just been checking there
are no
brick walls that aren't within private
ownership on this particular development
um it's probably the first thing to say
the the second thing to say is that
you know we're we're based in paris and
edmonds as blog we know we take a
a special interest in every site that we
have whether it's a historic site or a
new
proposed site like like this
um
we haven't had any issues and i'm sure
that the planning office will be able to
confirm that with any of our sites and
we've built a number of sites in in in
the district um and in the county
um
we do take
the management companies very very
seriously and and as a board of
directors we take them to task if
you know the quality and the standards
aren't there because we hear about it
from our our residents both in a short
term and and over the long term as well
so we are committed to ensuring that
none of the problems you've described uh
persist and will be dealt with as soon
as we're made aware of them
thank you going to the busbridge
thanks could you explain your the
process that you undertake to come up
with your mix of housing please
yeah so it's a
collaborative approach in in in many
ways we
first of all have a look at obviously
the site the location of the site where
we believe
um a
a sales mix
would
be positive for for us we then look at
things like us whether there's a smart
whether there's a local plan what that
identifies
um
and then we have within negotiation with
the council in terms of
what uh what they would anticipate to
see and it's a collaborative effort to
get us to to
to a point and particularly where we are
now
it just seems that you if you started
with the our strategic housing
requirements
you're miles off
is it i mean do you do you start with
what we want is 154 bedroom houses on
the on one hand and our requirements on
the other and try and negotiate your way
to somewhere in the middle or i mean do
you take any notice of our strategic
plan
if i can come in chair uh i i think the
important thing to remember uh on the
point that councillor busby's making
uh the shema covers the whole of the
district so it covers the whole of the
area which includes towns and includes
hamlets and everything in between
and these are the requirements that are
tried to meet in terms of your
larger
properties but also the smaller
properties as well and the skill is to
be able to work out what is the
requirement for that particular
settlement for that particular site uh
it has to start somewhere uh and
obviously bloor employ their people who
sell properties in a local area uh and
at the end of the day that's their
background their business uh so it comes
to a point where something is presented
to the local authority usually through a
pre-application process to say this is a
site these are the number of units and
this is how we would break down those
units into this type of mix and
we we have
discussions all the way through the
process before an application is
submitted particularly with your offices
at the strategic housing level so that
includes both the market housing as well
as particularly
on the affordable so it's not something
that we necessarily make up because at
the end of the day it's about selling a
product and if you've got the product
wrong you would be getting that
particular mix wrong there but it is
about a negotiation and it's not
something that simply uh come up with
themselves it is a process very much
like we're talking about with some of
these different designs and and
different types of of rendering material
the housing meeting's exactly that as
well it's got to be something that uh
that is profitable but it also has to be
something that is what is needed for
that particular area so i i'd like to
say council of buzzbee it's not
something that we come up with ourselves
it's a collective process uh on there
and i think that we've heard from the
from the parish that they were pleased
with some of the areas that we've got to
probably doesn't go far enough from from
their perspective but it is again about
the negotiation and the the larger
number of properties the four bedroom
properties as we've seen this morning
has actually been reduced as a result of
that negotiation as well
thank you
sorry just just just to add on to that
as well is that you know the housing
industry over
the last 18 months during covid has
has um has had an impact on the housing
market and the type of properties that
people are looking for
i imagine a number of us here worked
from home or work from a home office or
or similar so you know we've been seeing
that particularly on the ground that
people are going in to purchase a house
with that mindset of one of the bedrooms
would be either in office or or at least
have the ability to be able to do that
so we are seeing that as a trend
going through a hole
yeah thank you um pick up on the pv
panel she says 26
what houses will there be going on when
you bring the site forward will they be
on affordable housing or will there be a
mixture on the site
and you said that every
occupier may have the opportunity to
upgrade to pv
um i just want assurances that they're
not all going unaffordable
because there is a long term cost
involved
um it may be a benefit to the
owner or the occupier if they were
unaffordable but there's also the
ongoing costs involved as we know
through the district council our pv
panels are quite costly to maintain
um the other thing 100 ev
facility on this state is there any
guarantee for network uk network power
that there is actually
enough supply to actually facilitate 100
ev charging or will it just be a token
gesture that then can't be connected up
so thank you
your questions there and there is an
actual slide i think in within vincent's
report that identifies where they're
going to be and they are it's private uh
dwellings that that they're
predominantly going on
um
the the
the purchaser offering if we like is as
an extra um which we're trialing in a
site that we've got with with this
district um planners in in stone snow
upland so again it'll be that's well in
advance of this site so it'd be
interesting to see what the the take-up
is of that will
predict you know
replicate that model if that is is
proved to be
successful
in in terms of ev
electric vehicle charging and how that's
done is has moved on quite significantly
in the last year we've been working with
uh gtc ukpn tri-connects the the big
utility companies to try and understand
how that works so it's just an issue
like yours described doesn't occur and
what they have told us is that they
designed the systems now to be a
balanced system so effectively if
everybody plugs if they've got a whole
site of 100 units that then plug all of
their cars in rather than the first
person at the front getting theirs
charleston and the one that the back
doesn't it's a smart system that
identifies the the draw if you like from
the substation and it gives a balanced
fill up
during the evening um
how it works i couldn't tell you because
i'm i'm not
from gtc or uk pm but they've given us
the assurances of the questions that
you've raised
just one other question jeff i mean the
cycling um the connectivity to the to
the village you mentioned cyclone
earlier was mentioned in vince's report
there are no specific cycleways aren't
there
and i believe historically the parish
has um some questions or have had
concerns with cyclists using the current
footways
so i'm just a little bit um
intrigued to know what connectivity for
cyclists there will be
other than the highway
again it's it's something that
the scheme was consulted on by by
highways there were a number of
connectivity points throughout
throughout the scheme
and it was it's not something that has
been raised to us in in any statutory
objection that that's what was required
council blasphemy you have another
question
well yes come back to your answer i
think if you just said profit
i think we'd have believed you
been nice to be honest which is good
and latest requirements
i think which is also good and that
gives us a steer if you say well look
things have changed since you did your
housing study because everybody's
working from home now therefore they
need extra room
therefore
we have taken that on board that will
also give us a message that we've got to
get our
strategic plan right
and we do need to do that but james i
mean if you say
it's in your air in this particular
development it's fine to have
forty percent fifty percent of four or
four bedroom houses because on perhaps
town
developments
will counter balance that off
really oh we're going you're going to be
saying that when we come to chilton and
woolsey grange
i suspect we won't be bulging with two
bedrooms and three bedroom towns is
necessarily on those bigger developments
and
should we
change our strategic plan so that it
reflects the results of every
approval that we've made
ultimately we'll get to the point where
we need a hundred percent two-bedroomed
houses because we've under-delivered in
each of the other
applications do you see you see where
i'm coming from but
i mean
the changes are great
they would have been
perfect if you'd have just gone that
extra mile a bit more as i said put more
than two
uh flint houses in there perhaps reduce
the four bedrooms by another five
increase the number of bungalows etc but
you know
it's certainly a downside better than it
was when it came to us in july
thank you encounter both councilor
hinton
thank you mr chairman cancer buzzy just
touched on one of the things i was going
to ask you about in that you've reduced
the number of four-bedroom homes
increased the number of two and threes
the number of bungalows still remains
solidly at six
yet we do tend to find that uh
bungalows are an increasing demand
across all developments across the
district
um and
also
smaller bungalows rather than big ones
you know any four bedroom bungalows or
anything like that we want the
smaller ones and also the second the
second part of my question would be to
do with uh
the
solar panels
um would they be what sort of system are
you
you
offering to potential residents
to have in store that has ones with
individual inverters on each panel or
one with the central inverter because we
know that central inverters have a habit
of
setting light to roofs whereas
individual inverters just tend to go pop
and then you've just got one panel that
doesn't work
thank you if i take the the the bungalow
point first on on site we've actually
got 14 bungalows um six of those are
private and and and the the remaining
eight are um are
affordable
so
but there are as i said so as an overall
there are 14
on on the development um in terms of the
the pv we we use a a company called
viridian whether they're single
inverters or or um
uh how that system works i i don't i
don't know this is the honest answer
you can it's just that uh
single a single inverter is cheaper to
install than individual panel inverters
so people tend to uh opt for the single
inverter rather than the individual ones
whereas the individual ones are a lot
safer
we would
for a technical detail like that we
would rely on the the manufacturer to
advise us what was
um
what was
appropriate in each individual design
circumstance so i i i don't know whether
they're individual or not but we rely
upon the manufacturer who would
obviously guarantee that
so can i just say we have put a slide on
on the screen to show the bungalows
thank you
any more questions
thank you chair um and this might come a
little bit out of left field actually um
this but um if if i made a chair during
my ward work um i'm raising the profile
within my parishes of defibrillators
[Music]
locally and it occurs to me mr chairman
that we've been missing a trick here
with with new build development
and i'm wondering if there isn't an
opportunity for us to inquire as to
the installation of defibrillators on
our new build uh developments as they
come forward
so what i'd like to ask mr clark if if
possible is is one do you um agree with
me that there's a very real public
benefit um
to defibrillators and and if you do
and in acknowledgment of our recently
passed wellbeing strategy uh would uh
bloors be prepared to install uh a
defibrillator on this site please
thank you
before you answer i i i think you must
be aware and i think the member of the
parish council
you do have a
scheme on melvin
already
well could i just
yeah but if i could just counter that
very point um i mean you're absolutely
right um and long malford particularly
uh have been very successful through the
efforts of council and none in
particular
installing a large number of
defibrillators and that's the point
because
you know the stats are that fewer than
one in ten people survive a cardiac
arrest
however where there is access to a
defibrillator within three to five
minutes uh the percentage rate of
survival goes to over 70 percent so it's
not a case of having one it's a case of
having a number of defibrillators dotted
around the village um but you know it
would be a real real tangible benefit to
the community
with a with a family with a history of
heart disease i
completely understand and agree where
you're coming from i would hope in the
spirit of ongoing communications with
the parish um that we would certainly be
able to
provide
something
and and identify a location and a time
frame for when that could be installed
any more questions
if not thank you very much
and we'll move on to the ward members
uh councillor none is unwell
so may i ask council melviezi to
address the committee you have five
minutes
thank you very much chairman and good
morning committee
following our last meeting along melford
parish council and blower homes met
several times to discuss the points and
issues raised when we were last before
planning committee headway was made as
evidenced by the document law holmes has
presented to committee today
however as my
co-counsellor
on long melford parish council
councillor watts
has mentioned there are still some
important reservations
primarily the lack of flint
rendered properties this is a site of
150 properties
halstead
had four or more
and we only have two
so i think we could maybe stretch a
little bit there i don't think the
offering is attractive enough melford
attracts a premium because of its
history it's three grade one listed
buildings its medieval and georgian
fronted cottages
which straddled the b1064
from the site entrance of this
development
the artist's impression of the main
square at the front of the development
while much improved still looks a little
urban in nature
additional planting is welcomed and one
hopes that the plants to be used while
count will counter the negative outputs
of fossil fuel driven machines
however
the area could be further broken up by
using different coloured block paving to
denote cycle only paths and
pedestrian-only pathways within the
shared space
the hammer heads
or turning areas still cause serious
concern especially when we see a plan
with the remaining field area marked as
in the applicant's control
however i'm given that this is just for
access but we shall see
these areas need to be planted with oaks
with a tree preservation order
applied to them immediately to ensure
that they are not tarmacked through
unfelt
however my personal concern is the
attenuation basins
we've had problems in long melford with
old suds and the management of which has
fallen away therefore as committee have
said
management plans must be addressed and
other items of concern to lmpc here is
the car parking on site we do not want
to see more cars parked along station
road
because there just isn't room
i believe that these plans need to be
worked on in conjunction with all
parties that includes the parish council
bloor and bdc planning
it's a shame that bloor didn't see fit
to provide at least some homes of grey
water facilities or ground thermal
heating systems
but they have provided the hydrogen kits
and they have provided or they will
provide for photovoltaic panels
i would ask
bloor present today to install amber led
lighting on the site and not blue white
lighting which is harmful to humans as
well as wildlife
well currently there's no mandatory
biodiversity net gain required however
the mppf encourages local planning
authorities to incorporate biodiversity
improvement in new developments
so it is much more around what
developers should do
the wildlife trusts and the rspb are
promoting that new developments should
be designed to integrate space for both
wildlife and people as well as to reduce
carbon emissions and minimize water
usage
they should be designed to retain and
fit in with the existing wildlife
friendly features such as meadows which
bloor have
arranged wetlands hedge trees and
woodland they should enhance this
network and establish green corridors
that contribute to the wider ecological
networks they should incorporate
wildlife rich gardens and other green
spaces they should include structural
features and enable birds bats and other
creatures to live in harmony and why do
i draw your attention to this because
schedule 14 of the environment bill
currently in the house of laws awaiting
its third reading on the 13th of october
amends the town and country planning act
1990 to make provision for the mandatory
delivery of 10
biodiversity net gain in any new
development the results in habitat loss
or degradation
ladies and gentlemen thank you very
much questions for the ward member
come to the beer uh yes mr chairman i've
got a question for the ward member
um regarding the park and as you know
i'm very concerned about park and
throughout the whole of the baby
district but um
and on this particular site they've got
garages and a parking space
how many
parking spaces do you want there and
how how
do you expect law to achieve that
because uh they're doing all what
they're required to do from what i mean
misinterpreted me and i probably didn't
explain myself
and
also while i'm still speaking it's quite
pleasing to know that the motorist
actually is leading the way you say
they're selling more electric cars this
is excellent we're doing our bit for the
green we i was talking about on-site
parking for the workers for the site
employees
can i answer that chair because i do
have an answer if it helps to cut
me as part of the construction
management plan counselor malveezy we
will actually identify the parking
compound areas for workers
so you're quite right what we don't want
them doing is parking out on station
hill we want it all to be contained
within the site and fortunately with a
site this size i fully expect blood to
be able to accommodate all of that
within their own site
if that helps that's good news because
i've raised it
because i'm also the ward member that
includes acton
and the development on tammi's road
the people in tammings road are
suffering from
employees of that site
parking on tamage road and it's causing
serious problems it is a perennial
problem but i'm confident
through that management plan and with
laws cooperation we can do this is why i
think we should be working together on
the management plan
thank you
any more questions
thank you very much
thank you thank you right
there's no more questions
we're open for debate would anybody like
to start
wish somebody else would anyway um well
just to say this to chairman um
uh very um sort of concerned in this
whole situation um
being at the previous meeting
this one reading all the paperwork now
in the area very well which i do
and the fact that they won another
appeal which i have to say was
disappointing to the locals than us but
there you are this is where we are
what you've now come forward with
is um i think a major improvement from
the previous one
and i think that um
vincent was quite right the office of
concern to congratulate you officers
but i think
and i'm going to congratulate us
planners because
we stood out we decided that we weren't
happy with what laws was putting forward
we were in touch with what people were
thinking and feeling we know what was
needed and they've listened and taken it
on board to a certain degree and and to
that i do thank them all right not a
hundred percent but then we can't always
get what we always want
um but we're certainly in the right
direction and even the motors is getting
a better um public press here so i'm
very pleased about that
um
i think at the end of the day
there are some
areas which are still uh up for
discussion i think our officers have
most likely got them well under control
and uh pursuing that
and what have you and um i think really
it only leaves me that i will move
approval of the officer's recommendation
i know it's early in the debate but um i
will do it anyway
thank you thank you councillor beer do
we have a seconder for his proposal
councillor busby thank you do you want
to say anything
it's unusual if you learned
no thank you okay thank you
um we have a proposal any more comments
to make council ahead
thank you mr chairman yes i think um
councillor beers
on the head a bit there there's been a
lot of work going on between parish
council developer planning department
etc and it seems to have come up with on
the balance of
planning matters which is what we always
have to consider rather than outright
black and white
something that is that could be deemed
to be acceptable it's not perfect by any
means but and it never will be
but i would also just like to say that
all these electric cars that are being
sold are all registered in milton keynes
which is why they've put in so many eb
charging points in milton keynes but
most of them aren't there of course
because they're just registered there by
companies and lease companies
so we've got to be a little bit careful
about some of these environmental
measures that we put in with the
maintenance of them because i've done
absolutely nothing to them since in
those seven years and they're still
working just as well as they were when
we first went up
so there there are some
environmental uh measures around that
are
easy to to incorporate into developments
and to housing
thank you any more comments from anyone
cancel
as i'm not here very often why not
um
observations really i think the entrance
into this state still looks so small i
mean i drive past it daily and i just
look at that and think how can you get
two cars in there so it's 5.5 meters
wide on the plan but i honestly don't
know that it just looks so small to me
going past it observation um
generally parking i think i'll take
advantage of being here strategically
within the district we have parking
issues this estate is not necessarily
going to help that at all
i think
for a long long time we've had um
a knock-on effect of planning laws sent
out from central government not really
facilitating
the vision of five ten years down the
road where these estates have
another number of cars as kids get older
they then come to drive a two household
car then comes a four household car
there's no spaces for them i think we
all acknowledge we've got a problem with
that but how we address it is really up
to central government but i'll raise
that here because i'm sure in 10 years
time there'll be parking issues on that
estate as there is in every other estate
within the district
um cycleways i touched on i don't know
if there is any provision in this
development for any money going forward
to cycle ways and connectivity as we
know we have our own lc whip coming
forward which is bringing forward some
suggestions on that and there may be
some schemes around melford that will
benefit from that
and the management plan again people
have raised concerns with management
plans
um we do have issues in the past as an
authority where management companies
have combust and we're left with the
maintenance of not only the
green space but the equipment and the
fencing that comes with it so i'm always
hesitant about management companies
because they can come and go
those really were my observations but
question really is are there any is
there any provision in this
development for cycleways and and what
what are they
thank you councillor holt the local
highway authority have required a cycle
connectivity
and i've even got the plan
in terms of the layout it's the northern
corner where the
estate connects to the existing footpath
system
so you would it's effectively connecting
it to roman road so you're right some of
it will be on roads
but within the estate there will be a
three meter wide connection
from
the footpath
connection into the estate
so it isn't a comprehensive three meter
wide
circular route around the development
it is the connection point
if we can get a slide up i'm just
thinking which slide would be best so
it's a short link out of the estate on
the highway yes so so that's it
oh here we go what's that
can i actually see a pointer yeah
no
how best to describe it
oh
there we go
so if we go left it's those of you can
remember bernie the bolt up a bit
up a bit more
and then left a bit
there we go bit more
there we go
do you see so that's where you'll be
able to with the three meter wide
connection you'll be able to link
between existing public rights way and
the estate
and that was the requirement of
the highway authority
and of course some of this we are
we are bound by what was discussed and
agreed by the inspector
at the appeal
i would want to point out if i may
through you chair the point you made
about parking in
modern estates
this development does meet your current
standards so
we can't push it any further
than that
council
i think i just want to add to um
the comments made by councillor beer i
think
recognizing where we were in july i
think we have got to acknowledge that
we've moved further forward and that's
very proactive for planning committees i
think as a planning committee
we set the bar but
i think we've got to acknowledge that
people have worked very hard since then
and
would that all planning applications
responded in that way
thank you chair
thank you council beer
thank you mr jim just follow on from
that point i think
you're quite right canceling the power
and i think the message we need to send
out to developers in baber
uh that we're expecting more of them and
we're demanding more of them and that
they need to take on board some of our
strong concerns and this particular
application is certainly addressing a
lot of those not all of them as members
have said but there's certainly right
direction they're not going to get an
easy ride in baby if they don't start to
play
active and what have you thank you
thank you councillor beer i'm just
disappointed we had to ask
why it wasn't offered at the beginning
council jameson
i think he's here uh while um he's
commendable and i'd like to thank
uh blah for going the extra nine percent
in the carbon reductions but they didn't
need to
he does highlight a worry going forward
for our local plan that having
the 19 companies are only going to go
just to that as much as they need to do
and then stop
it
doesn't seem to encourage them to go
a little bit further to make um
the
uh to add the benefits that would make a
real difference and then
going forward that's all they're going
to do they're just going to go to the 90
and stop and um that's a worry going
forward i mean it'd be nice if we could
get some way companies to go and put pv
panels on all
premises or
do nothing more insulation than the 19
but we know going forward they won't do
that which is a bit of a worry
we might even ask whether they will
offer it as an extra
that's right
so you can purchase it with the house
yeah
well not all rules will face in the
right direction i know
i live in one myself um
any more comments to make
if not we have a proposer and secondary
oh sorry chairman if i could just come
in because councillor parker talked
about defibrillators and i just want to
be comfortable that council parker was
happy we took that away in discussion
with the applicant and
it could be argued to be a part of the
landscaping detail and for us to
come to an amendment of the
details before you to include that in
some appropriate location if that's
acceptable and that will obviously need
to be something that the proposal and
second of the motion want to take on
board accept that
well i'm not so sure because the local
county councillor for that area
has locality money which uh quite often
we spend on defibrillators and i've put
some in great corner and i'm quite sure
that the paris council could go along to
them i don't know i'm not saying that
the um this particular application
shouldn't put in one um but i don't
think that should be a condition
that i want to add onto mine thank you
how about your second though
yes
i trust law to do the right thing
happy to go with that and we'll simply
add an informative note to reflect the
debate today
okay
fine
we have an unknown unadulterated
proposal
um
shall we go to the road
no more comments
thank you chair that vote is now in
progress members
done
one
thank you members chair that's 11 votes
for that's unanimous that's relentless
thank you very much and thank you for
our guest today
thank you for attending our next meeting
is on the 20th of october
you